you are mentioning this because what's
happening now they made it seem like if
you don't not agree that Jewish people
were practically were oppressed you evil
man God what were the Jewish people that
the people that have killed the women
and children why we should not have the
day for the Canaanite day that they've
been killed and just the children
Algeria now we're in the clouds
the people that you killed and Justice
I mean they choose people I just showed
you in the Bible killing babies
[Music]
from God
I don't know because you know what I
don't know I'm gonna use it and guess
how I don't know
are yours
basically are your pick and choose
that God gave it to Moses
huh you've got it I gave it to Moses he
says nothing good it's always lying you
oh God
I didn't write the story I said to you
is a Torah from God you said no yes he
says God gave it to Moses yeah
in the Torah says God gave it to Moses
that's a lie
uh
Lies when you write something knowing
that it's not true I think Moses Smith
was an incredibly wise man and his
writings are Divine in the sense that
they're eternally God equality so I
wouldn't call it Allah
many many things in the Torah I believe
are for Eternal moral truths maybe
Divine in that sense but I don't believe
that they are the National one of God so
you don't believe that basically liberal
you're a Liberal Liberal Jewish
yesterday
my criteria
I'm not talking about your people excuse
me we're talking about what is your
criteria
you know that your worshiping God
correctly
so maybe you are worshiping a God no no
no no
there's no problem
so therefore you can be worship God
incorrectly sure well no I mean in the
rare occasion that I pray I will pray
for the tradition of my ancestors which
is the rabbinical tradition here so
that's what I'm saying so you know I
forgot all of this
they're looking good yeah you believe in
God alone and follow the teacher most
and Prophet Muhammad yeah you know
yes
listen man can we stick on one thing on
the other things now stick to this
because you if you don't believe in God
actually there's a bigger problem
s I'd rather not talk about religion
we know we get in the world it's more
important than anything else
online because if you die yeah if I die
and I don't believe in God and I'll
Define the Palestine I want to benefit
me before God you know because believe
in God is the first the first
commandment in the Torah what is it
and to love him
yeah yeah how are you gonna love him if
you don't know what makes him what is
the thing that you should do to love it
to gain his love how can you do that
Divine scripture
[Music]
the only method the correct one it has
to come support himself
that's why God said Moses so you don't
believe in Moses the prophet of God
no no I know that existed prophet of God
yeah and the Bible I don't know yeah he
spoke to God and God spoke to him I
don't know
Abraham
okay so now what do you think you have
arrived over Palestine
wow where did this come from you know
why because in the Bible in the Bible
you have no they use the Bible say they
have a right of a Palestine the founders
of Zionism
secularist atheist now who gave your
rights over Palestine
imagine I come to a zulian I come to
Britain as a Britain this is my country
you're gonna ask me why all right listen
God told me it's my country yeah oh
because I'm just saying it because you
know my people existed here one thousand
years ago therefore is my country okay
for them anyway
I need to understand
what basis you would give someone a
right to a land
um just tell me so I can answer your
questions
yeah actually okay how prove to me that
Palestine belong to you good to me but I
don't know what your question no you
said to me three thousand years is your
country said three thousand years yeah
and you trust in what it's in a Bible
okay but we were debating
exists in 1948
there are many there are there are many
ways to answer your question I'm asking
a simple question yeah why because the
Muslim rude Palestine for nearly 1 000
years yeah so why you come take over
years
[Music]
let's see they conquered in around 700
and the British conquered in 1917 so
that
uh
yeah that's 1 200 years so do you accept
that yes so why you can take over who
gave your rights come take over what two
different questions no it's not it's
connected
right that's the question that's the
question I
[Music]
yeah this person okay in every single
generation three times a day Jews yearn
to return and in many occasions they
tried
this yearning never ever stopped every
day we pray to return to Jerusalem every
day we pray to restore the independence
in our land
any Jewish friends yeah
because that information that Jews were
praying for this no no that information
about the Romans and you came and it
took over yeah
but that's what I mean
yeah my point here is you get that
information from that book that you came
took over you know oh God gave it to you
then I didn't mention God no no but I'm
talking about that my point here is you
said there was a cannonite there before
Israel yes
you're just saying it
saying what the Bible says okay no
problem I just want to double check yeah
so my point here is you gave me took
over the country of the Canon night
Palestinians yes and it's been used the
word Philistines yes the fish team come
later but
now before that because I want to
understand you correctly and I want to
see that you're gonna buy no choice
you're gonna go back to the Old
Testament to verify or to justify your
points all right let's go back so they
were kind of night there yeah correct so
who told the Jewish people to go and
take over
according to the Bible
according to his rights for people to
come take over country
to tell me which one you so what do you
believe about what
ah brother is he taking a nick
I'm serious I'm not as intelligent as
dude no no I'm not pushing simply yeah
you said to me because I know if you
don't know who's a Torah you have no
justification to come to Palestine to
begin with huh
belong to them yeah
is that just sorry sorry is that just
the way you friendship correct but
you're good at it
agree with the way you freeze it I'm
safe
crazy always explain about national law
is your criteria it's not it's
International what is your criteria is
thank
you to find first 20 21 of the Quran
says that God today
check that if that's your own criteria
plays for the Muslims but that is what
that trap come from it belongs to the
Muslims so
[Music]
Arda
you see please you know Papa
come back come back before I get the
verse come back I'm asking you
other other
um
[Music]
before my criteria because I'll see you
twisting again before my criteria
Palestine let us go back to main points
you know what because I know for a fact
you're gonna go to the back to Torah the
Old Testament
okay so why you think you have the right
to come and take over our country which
belongs
long
ruling okay who is ruling before Jacob
existed who is there in that box
the hustle to the original points
because you said he said to me Israel
existed three thousand years
okay three thousand years yes before
that that country was belongs to
specific people yeah who gave them a
right to come and take over and where is
the proof they came and took over
you think the world cared about rights
back then then I'll ask about right no
no I'm asking you would you so who gave
you the right and where did you get the
information that you came and took over
here
yes of course
no one can you think people care about
rights 3 000 years ago of course they
come out right maybe you people didn't
come out
or something
Abraham how many years was he in life
with his father even if your father
non-believer he's right as a father to
respect him that's called a human rights
there are so many ways no I know you're
gonna get trapped you know for a fact
you can get shot that's why you keep
playing
okay let me just take you so one
thousand years the Muslims ruled like
you said 1 200 years and then you keep
playing with the old one because the
information of the Jewish people came
from over Palestine is in the Old
Testament you know we diggle in the land
we find Jewish artifacts we find Hebrew
there's archaeological evidence that the
Jews were there it's not just based on
the turret no no there's no actual
there's there's
Jewish people who said they've improved
that most existed
what do you say
about Jewish control over the land of
Israel for which there is a myriad of
archaeological evidence okay so
according to our colleges Jewish people
that the the the the the the Solomon
Prophet Solomon he's even his Empire he
was very tiny
so anyway the points anyway so who gave
you the right and would you get the
information
all right okay we'll give you the right
to come say oh our Consciousness belong
to the Muslims
1000 years
okay now please answer my question
be the right to come and take because if
you're gonna tell me they're cool
correct all right the Christians the
Jewish people they're working and the
rooster people the Christians
are you aware of that Israelites yeah
the Christians come took over yeah why
don't you go back and say oh because you
were there before them
in Spain oh you don't live in Spain
let's stop playing around with me you
actually don't play around anyway my
point here why you can't take over a
country is not belong to you British
gave you something does not belong to
them no it does belong to us and I'll
tell you why Wow one nation states that
has existed that the only people to have
ever had in nation-state an independent
Kingdom in Palestine on the Jews before
so how many years that how many years
how many years before the Muslims came
came when 700 with the Muslims game is
under the Christians yes so for more
than 800 years you had no rule over
itself
it was under the Romans yes it was under
the Romans yeah that the Muslim can't
take over it was even under you at all
so nearly 2 000 years it was under the
Christians
Palestine no other countries
thank you very much the United States
they gave you the right
and oppression because there's an
envelope to them thank you for being
honest
therefore you are oppressing people by
taking over a country does not belong to
you
I'm sorry what does that means
Jewish anyway
foreign
right
[Music]
because under Judah that the Judah yes I
know that yes yes so what does that mean
so what about the other Jewish people
uh Joseph
your great grandfather is in Palestine
in Europe we family in Palestine since
or your family of your grandfather your
granddad yeah
no problem
you have to be careful no way because we
don't play around with this stuff you
know because we were occupied for more
than 32 years and we never back down and
my brothers and six Palestinians they
were never back down and when they were
over for you you have a righteous
they're no doubt because as a Jewish
person but I'm not over country and kill
the people you know and what I was going
to say to you about using Mela forbid to
become a Muslim Washington
my family is in Palestine
76 yeah for a long time but a lot of
them came from Britain
no no no only people some of you came
from Europe from Russia yeah
for all Jewish people there you have to
have to find a tree
for United Nations to give you a place
that does not belong to them okay
by what criteria are you making making
the Judgment of
that run no I'm saying to you okay
you said your criteria is gone for 1000
Years
okay yes
so you come to our country I mean even
the people that were Muslims they were
originally there before
it's just once again I'm gonna say how
long is that 1200 degrees
[Laughter]
the people of Spain accepted Islam
indigenous people in Palestine when
Islam came to them except Islam it's
their country and you came by the aid of
the United scorpions and they put you
there why didn't you put you in you know
they gave you they gave you Argentina
Uganda thank you Uganda
but just so I know
yeah yeah
no don't say that
it's a light and you have no country to
begin with no no I mean that's what it
was
according to you Joshua come to the land
and the English what can you do
you said that the the Israelites
confidential right
didn't you say that
establishing you you justify know you
but many Choice people with citizen they
justify quotation to Palestine by saying
God gave it to us
by now he said as she said she said the
United
Nations United Nations
let's
[Music]
the people that believe in there for
centuries
sure
prove that something you've been living
there for three thousand years
Joshua never existed A Thousand Years
requirement
S I know it's a Bible no it's not the
Bible
you find Jewish artifacts you find
Palestine artifacts right before you
that's not true but fine no problem
they didn't exist three thousand years
ago okay so you're telling me before
Israel you was born there was no one
ruled out over Palestine
for Israel you mean the motivation no
Jacob who said three thousand years yeah
three thousand years Jacob came about
so before Jacob there was no one ruling
after ruling over Palestine so he's
saying
we can't write so who are the Indigent
people
who aren't indigenous people
who are the indigenous people
so by the way I could be wrong
[Music]
I think
I could be wrong with this but the only
real Source from the time in the Bible
the Bible says there's a kind that's
actually came from Africa but it could
be wrongful the Bible launched at the
Bible no I'm saying I've only sourced
from the time yeah so why we don't trust
it we don't trust it
is
[Laughter]
application
the most important that you understand
that you're here to support will you
understand that you understand
everything so are you ready to speak
about both
no no our thoughts
very much
old enough to get five more pregnancies
as a young person
nothing
but it's not part of the life and okay I
believe in God what is the correct way
to believe in God and you know your
answer says
sorry ancestors
[Music]
so like 600 yeah probably down December
yeah yeah we're already in Europe man
yeah we're already in Europe I didn't
think I descend from him
I'm a Muslim she's Jewish
is Muslims even though we're not direct
us
understand that definition
ancestors
okay
you learned something new every day yeah
when we tell you why the Jewish people
came to Medina
you know they're capes Medina
yeah yeah do you know why they moved to
Medina why
because they were expecting for a
prophet to come
in Isaiah 42.
you accept that yeah
right
gentlemen
yeah
don't have enough
money
is my second language
because the language is similar it flows
much better it's true it's a semantic
language
here is my service
My Chosen One yeah
I Delight I will be I will put my spirit
on him and will bring Justice to the
Nations yeah he will not shout or cry
out or raise his voice in the streets
the Bruce Lee he will not break but
watch I'm gonna show you something
sing to the Lord new song yeah okay
uh he's praised from the ends of the
Earth you will go down to the Sea and
all that is in it you islands and all
who lives in them let the witness and
his town raise their voice the
settlements where Keda lives rejoice
okay that if you go to Genesis 25 13
it's the son of Ishmael 25 13 Genesis
said it's the Sun Shine the first one is
the second one is Kayla yes so he speaks
about okay let the people of Selah seek
for a joy we're a Stella Zella is a rock
no that's the name of the rock not as a
rock
okay where is
letting people rejoice
[Music]
go on safariable
translations
as far as I know the word shield never
means low no here you know there's
Sometimes some words in the in the Torah
is metaphorical
descendants of Ishmael
why
you know what do you want from me no I'm
saying that use your brain mother use
this box you have use your Apple use
your intellect okay that's what I'm
saying my point is the Jewish rabbis
they use this passage to validate
validates
[Music]
have a nice evening